cuéntenos qué implica que haya datos
insuficientes para establecer el nivel
de peligro en el que se encuentra una
especie
Santos que me da muchas gracias por la
invitación Sí pues en realidad
desconocemos aún todavía la
biodiversidad total del planeta en
realidad no sabemos Cuántas especies hay
en nuestro planeta hay estimados de uno
de dos de dos millones ocho millones 30
millones O 100 millones lo cual
significa que aún no conocemos todas las
especies que coexisten en nuestro
planeta a eso se refiere cuando hay
datos insuficientes Hay muchas que
Todavía existen dentro de las selvas
impenetrables del Congo del Amazonas o
alejadas en la tundra de de Siberia que
no han sido registradas por la ciencia
no tienen un nombre científico Por lo
cual no conocemos su existencia pero no
podemos negar de que existen estos
lugares que estén ahí Entonces esto es a
lo que se refiere con que hay datos
insuficientes nos faltarían todavía
muchísimas generaciones de
investigadores para poder conocer tan
solo esta información básica que es la
respuesta a la pregunta Cuántas especies
hay en el planeta
claro y ahora porque es tan difícil
recabar datos de especies como los
anfibios que se mencionan en la
publicación de nature Cuál es el proceso
por ejemplo para decir que un ser vivo
está en peligro de extinción
Sí claro Hay varias categorías de riesgo
por la unión trasera de la conservación
de la naturaleza donde se ve por ejemplo
el cuando hay datos suficientes Bueno
pues ya es directo cuando vemos que en
los hábitats que eso es lo que está
sucediendo todo el planeta se están
reduciendo algunas de las especies se
ponen inmediatamente las categorías
altas de riesgo sobre todo si estas
especies son endémicas que significa
esto que existan en una en un solo lugar
y en ninguna otra parte del mundo y este
puede ser una laguna una cueva o un
sitio muy pequeño esas especies se ponen
inmediatamente en los puntos más altos
de categoría de riesgo y que hablamos de
los vertebrados como en el caso de los
anfibios es hasta cierto punto un poco
más sencillo porque pues porque los
podemos ver aunque todavía se inscriben
especies nuevas y cada cierto tiempo
pero si nos vamos al mundo de los
invertebrados o más allá de los
protozoarios o de las plantas Todavía
siguen muchísimas especies sin descubrir
y por supuesto categorizar en algún en
alguna categoría de riesgo señor rojo
Cuál es la población de Vida Salvaje que
queda en el mundo y cómo ha sido ese
decrecimiento a lo largo de los años y
que han logrado los esfuerzos de
conservación
vivimos actualmente una grave crisis de
pérdida de biodiversidad eso muchas
veces no ponemos la atención suficiente
Pero sabemos que estamos viviendo ahora
ya mismo la sexta extinción masiva esto
es que significa que la última La Última
extensión masiva que hubo en el planeta
fue cuando se murió la mayoría de los
grandes dinosaurios hace 76 millones de
años pero el día de hoy ya estamos
pasando por esta extinción masiva debido
principalmente a actividad humana se
sabe que la tasa de desaparición de las
especies es entre 100 y 1000 veces más
alta de la que hubo en la última
extinción masiva Estamos perdiendo
especies a la velocidad de una de una a
tres especies cada hora y esto nos da
cifras de entre 10.000 40.000 especies
de vida que estamos perdiendo en nuestro
planeta cada año y eso no puede seguir
sucediendo ya que nosotros dependemos de
la biodiversidad somos parte de ella y
podemos estar aislados Y esto es
principalmente por la deforestación que
hay en el planeta cambios de uso de
suelo contaminación cambio climático y
muchas otras cosas que estamos haciendo
como seres humanos que deberíamos
entender y detener en este mismo momento
porque no podemos sobrevivir sin nuestra
biodiversidad y yo vivo en un país mega
diverso como es México y tenemos que
poner especial atención en la protección
de los ecosistemas en los países
megadiversos Entonces el planeta pero en
los países megadiversos principalmente
de aquellos albergan el 70% de la vida
en nuestro planeta